hey there welcome to con O'Brien needs a
friend joined as always by Sona mesan
how are you Sona I'm all right yeah I'm
all right okay nice I'm good all right
okay that's weird uh Matt gorley how are
you I'm okay but I'm worried about Sona
what is that say I because if if I say a
one onew answer it's like not enough so
I I thought I'd J it up a little oh
that's you Jing it up yeah that's with Z
how would you how was it if every time
the podcast started I was like Hey Conan
how are you doing
I'm doing really well thank you very
much okay appreciate it I really do
appreciate it why you you're not going
to be that cordial you have a very uh
comp powerful sophisticated uh
microphone inches from your mouth and
you're constantly yelling is that
Eduardo is her volume an
issue no I be honest be honest be honest
he's married to an Armenian girl so you
know he knows what's up so is this just
an it's an Armenian thing I have the
filter on
yes
this is the uh you guys speak very
loudly to each other in your house yes
we do now you've got me all now now you
now you've got me you can't even do it
you can't even do it you can't even
whisper you know what' be so funny if
you were in any kind of job that
required you to whisper and you couldn't
do it
librarian you guys they welcome to the
library hey welcome to the neonatal
w now we do try to use softer voices
here I'm telling people to be quiet and
I can't do it you can't do it okay I'm
also leaning into the mic I don't need
to do that no you don't I get no I mean
I'm surprised Eduardo I'm always looking
over Eduardo and thinking that small
fires are breaking out on his control
board because I mean that is a lot well
you know you're pretty loud too in fact
I've got my headphones turned down
really low to the point where it's
mostly like a mix of the outside sound
and then both of you cuz you yell a lot
too oh
okay the term we like to use Conan
you're very
dynamic dynamic I think I have a great
performance energy that has been a
Hallmark of my career yeah uh and so I
have a real performance energy has been
a homework of my career yeah wow you uh
you got me pretty good you did you got
me pretty good I no no and you know what
to be fair that was pretty good you
really you took me down a eye D I didn't
see that coming I didn't see that
character
coming um but I mean do you when you've
put your your children to sleep is it a
problem do you when you then lean in and
go night night guys is it a problem are
you you're not asking for reals no I'm
having fun yeah I know you are yeah yeah
no I I I'm a loud person I come from a
loud house you say how do you say good
night to them she shed potty oh come on
they've got to learn they've got to
learn I want be able to get jobs in
America they're going to learn good
night now they're going to be bilingual
oh it's cool to be bilingual every
Christmas season it's the same thing
demands for more podcast episode comes
in and we've got to meet those demands
we got to mail out those podcasts we got
to get them in the mail I well guess
what with stamps.com all you need is a
computer and printer then you're ready
for that Holiday Rush you know what I'm
saying no I'm remember last year when we
were stuffing podcast into envelopes and
licking them and putting on the stamps
it was crazy in here yeah no more not
with stamps.com they even send you a
free scale so you have everything you
need to get started cuz whenever I go to
mail stuff out I'm like where's my scale
well they got the scale ready there for
you now taking care of orders on the go
is even easier with the stamps.com
mobile app if you need a package pickup
you can easily schedule it through your
stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace in shopping
cart get your business ready for the
holiday Rush get started with stamps.com
today sign up at stamps.com Conan for a
special offer that includes a 4-week
trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Conan
when are you going to teach them what's
the one you say Ked potty okay but when
are you going to teach them uh when are
they going to learn good night they
learn good night from they watch TV
they watch stuff you let them watch
yeah they watch
wait what what are they watching
what I mean I mean like they learn
English but you know we we mostly speak
to them Armenian and then they watch TV
and stuff and right yeah so they what
are they watching they watching kids
shows or do you have them watching what
are they watching they watch like their
favorite movies right my neighbor todoro
and The Fantastic Mr Fox and Ratatouille
and Nemo are like what's what's up in
our house that's what's happening that's
some good stuff yeah I'm trying to get
them into the Iron Giant but they're
just like scared of the robot like come
on grow will
Paar who tells their who tells their
little boys to grow a pair first of all
they need to grow two pair they don't
each get one
testicle hey guys grow a pair
what we only get one don't speak English
or you'll get a
beaten God all right all right well we
just got to peek into your world did no
one speak GIC in your
house yes all Irish people speak gayc I
don't know I don't know I don't even
honestly know what Gaelic sounds like
isn't Irish old Irish just called Irish
right Am I Wrong is gaic Scottish no
gaay is yeah then I'll cut that I look
like a fool no you have to keep that in
Irish a fool yeah but no you got to keep
that in G is is the old uh you know
language langage of of that island of
that particular Island does your family
speak gelx of course not are we sorry
the only way that the only Irish thing
about us is that I grew up hearing a lot
of Jesus Mary and Joseph and Jesus
Christ Jesus Mary and Joseph and it was
constantly the response to everything
and I think that that's but I but I
don't even think I thought that that was
a Catholic thing and then um I knew that
uh when I first started working with
Robert Smigel he'd be like oh Jesus
Christ what are we GNA do and I'm like
oh okay Jewish people say Jesus yeah
everyone I think I think it's thing that
a lot of people say yeah I realize I
thought it was just Catholics that said
that